all right we are live on rumble on
youtube on blaze tv i'm dave rubin and
welcome to another friday round table
extravaganza joining me today is the
co-host of you are here on blaze tv my
old buddy elijah schaefer author of
viral the search for the origin of kobit
19 matt ridley and nfl player turned
army ranger turned u.s senate candidate
in arkansas jake beckett guys welcome to
the reuben report
great to be with you thank you all right
it was a nutty week that we're closing
up shop obviously this millet story
is the big one but we got to do some
covid stuff and then i want to talk
about the imaginary war that the neocons
seem to want to get us into involving
russia and ukraine but let's start with
some kovid stuff because matt you just
wrote a really excellent book about the
origins of covid and we've just watched
the definitions of everything change
phrases we used to say two weeks to
flatten the curve heard immunity that we
don't talk about anymore etc etc here
was uh anthony fauci this week on the
definition of being vaccinated
is it a matter now of when
not if the definition of fully
vaccinated changes
you know my own personal opinion kate is
what you said is correct it's going to
be a matter of when not if
matt
we're already changing the definition of
fully vaccinated it's not one shot it's
not two shot maybe it's a third booster
a fourth shot wrap your head in saran
wrap what's going on here
well
i'm i'm boost boosted i've had two
vaccines and a boost in a booster and uh
uh you know the it does help there's no
question about it um uh the the the
evidence that it uh at least lessens the
significance of i mean the virulence of
an outbreak is is there um but you're
right this moving of goal posts is is a
real issue and the changing of the names
and the rules and everything and let's
remember it's now two years since the
first known case pretty well today
actually uh in that market in wuhan in
december 2019 two years into this
pandemic we're still struggling to
escape from it uh it's done terrible
damage to the world economy it's killed
millions of people it's caused an
outbreak of authoritarianism like i
thought i'd never see in my lifetime
even in western countries and we don't
really know where it came from that's
what our book is about trying to
understand and uh you know frankly there
have been cover-ups there have been
obsession there's been a blockage of
information it's disgraceful you know we
ought to know so we can stop this
happening again exactly how this started
to that point elijah i know you and i
are pretty aligned on this stuff i mean
do you trust any of these guys anymore
okay now the fda says this the nih says
this
you know
pfizer says this and then it just gets
repeated on corporate media
no yeah i don't trust these people
obviously if your viewers aren't
familiar my background is in
specifically genetic engineering and
molecular biology specifically in
immunological delivery systems like this
and uh you know i mean i've worked with
these kinds of systems in the vaccine uh
obviously again like if i was older if i
was over 60 and i had a comorbidities i
might take the vaccine if i'm under 45 i
just wouldn't take it and that's that's
the problem with this is that
there is absolutely no evidentiary truth
to anything that the who or the cdc
continues to put out in fact the wh on
the cdc can't even align on basic tenets
of who is most benefited by the vaccine
and that's the problem is that if if
they had come out and just said hey look
if you've got two to four co-morbidities
and you're over 30 years old or if
you've got one to three and you're over
55 here's how many shots you should take
and if you're over 65 maybe get the
boosters but no they're trying to inject
this into infants they're even testing
and trying to say how low can we go how
much money can we make and like uh
you're you know just like your other
guest just said
you know i have to ask myself the
question if this is about science if
this is about um protecting the public
why are we using science uh as a noun
and not as a verb as in the science is
settled not science as a discipline of
continual understanding and why if it's
about science is it leading to
authoritarianism and lockdowns i believe
it's fully nefarious and i think that
you know where where the pandemic began
or started i think it started from the
lab in wuhan youtube says it didn't but
uh
that's that's up to them i'll let matt
jump back in on that since he just wrote
a book about the whole thing but jake uh
you're running for senate in arkansas
you mentioned right when we jumped on
before we started the live stream the
things are pretty good in arkansas
how much of this the creeping
authoritarianism the state's rights
stuff the inability for the federal
government to manage this at any level
whatsoever how much of this is all
playing into why you're getting into
politics
well it plays a lot it's a large part
because you know i've seen how we have
ceded our our liberty as as free
citizens of a constitutional republic
to an unaccountable scientific elite as
president dwight eisenhower so
presciently warned us of in his 1960
farewell address it's hard to believe
that was over 61 years ago but we're
seeing those consequences happen today
right now and i think elijah is exactly
right look these these bureaucrats these
these so-called elites they have no idea
how to manage this virus the only way
through this is to continue to live our
lives there's no way that we can really
mitigate the risk through continual
injections of these vaccines i think
it's clear that the big pharma and the
government are working hand in hand to
essentially get every citizen of the
united states on a a never-ending cycle
of vaccine after vaccine after vaccine
we saw the announcement today the uh the
governor of new york uh just put in more
tyrannical mandates on businesses all
across her state either mandate vaccines
or there's a masked mandate inside
private businesses it's totally out of
control it's orwellian and that's one of
the reasons why i'm running for u.s
senate is because the leaders even in
the republican party who we've sent to
you know protect us from government
overreach have simply not done their job
we have to have real conservative
warriors pro-liberty warriors who can
defend the freedom free citizens of this
country who are still upset and want to
fight back against this tyranny you're
speaking my language man and you know if
you want to you mentioned new york if
you want to know how stupid it is here
in l.a my producer mentioned to me that
he went to see kanye last night in la 90
000 people uh and yet you still have to
wear a mask if you go to the supermarket
here in los angeles so none of it makes
any sense uh but matt let me back up to
you for a second because on this on the
origins of kobit which is what your book
is all about there was this weird thing
online where for basically a year there
were a lot of people saying you know
maybe this did kind of come out of the
wuhan lab and let's talk about it a lot
of people were banned or silenced or
de-boosted shadow band whatever it might
be then jon stewart goes on was it
colbert i think and basically says hey
maybe it's real and the next thing you
know mainstream media can kind of talk
about it but now we're not talking about
it again we seem to have left so so
what's going on here
yeah you're dead right there was an
appalling appalling attempt to
censor away the possibility that this
was um a laboratory origin virus um
you know there's a there's a lab in
wuhan which is the leading lab in the
world by a mile for researching bat born
coronaviruses sars like coronaviruses
and uh
it's produced hundreds of papers it's
collected tens of thousands of samples
of viruses from all over southern china
and neighboring countries
these come from a long way away from
wuhan they don't come from the
neighborhood of wuhan they've been doing
an immense amount of research they've
published work showing that they've
hybridized and made chimera viruses
manipulated these viruses inserted genes
into them
done putting put them into uh uh
humanized mice and human cells in the
lab to test them
there's a massive program going on
nowhere else but wuhan and then suddenly
in the at the end of 2019 a disease
caused by one of these verses breaks out
in wuhan
and at first everyone says well it must
be the market people have said well then
it turns out they've tested tens of
thousands of animals in in and around
china and they haven't found a single
one carrying this virus so you know
prima facie you've got to take seriously
the possibility that this came out of a
laboratory now we don't claim in our
book that we know the answer but we do
show very strong evidence as to why we
now lean towards
a lab leak as an explanation
and as you say we've spent 18 months
being told that that's a nutty
conspiracy theory that shouldn't be
allowed in in mainstream media
and you know why why should we censor a
perfectly reasonable scientific
discussion of this kind and it's it's
happening again i mean you know they're
trying to shut down our book basically
you know by
trying to make sure it gets bad reviews
and doesn't get on air and this is a
this is a really important topic yeah
absolutely well we're going to make sure
that the link to the book is in the
description so people can check it out
without algorithmic manipulation
although who knows what they're doing to
this show
elijah
in terms of the media ever getting to
the bottom of this like should we just
not even pretend that these people are
going to try at this point
yeah we shouldn't i mean dave to kind of
put this into perspective a funny story
is a buddy of mine just called me last
night and he got
diagnosed with the omicron the faded
virus that we all need to lock down over
uh out in la and uh i asked him well
where did you get this from he's not
vaccinated he had the uh notorious alpha
variant um that was out there that we
all you know were locked down over uh i
believe less people were dying around
the same time last year you know it
depends on what week you're talking
about but anyway uh you know i was like
where'd you get it from he's like well i
had the alpha variant and i got this
it's real mild doesn't matter i got it
from a girl who's actually gotten all of
her vaccines and never got the uh the
virus she she had she and she all she
basically got coveted only twice but
after she got the uh vaccines then i
just said you know what this is so effed
up this is so screwed up man i mean
you're telling me that it's the it's the
unvaccinated that are a danger but you
got it from the vaccinated girl and her
symptoms are stronger than yours and i
don't think the media has any interest
of telling that story luckily people
like you in your show i'm able to tell
that story here i just think that the
media is an extension of the
authoritarian paramilitary medical
tyrannical uh
arm of the world right now which is you
know use this pandemic as a means
whether they caused it intentionally
unintentionally i don't know
but they're using this to get their way
and no don lemon you know if he doesn't
get fired for his misconduct he is he
doesn't want to tell america the truth
the young turks they're they make they
have a business model out of lying
intentionally and then any other media
including this one if we're trying to
tell the truth the big tech companies
come into play and they say well if you
tell too much of the truth then we're
gonna you know we're gonna mess with you
we're gonna screw with you we'll delete
you we'll de-monetize you there's no
merit to tell the truth luckily people
like you are taking the risk by having
guests like this on uh but i don't think
i think if people want to know the truth
you should read you know like the book
on the show that's there you should
actually do your own research because
the legacy media is here to delude you
and to keep you under control and we've
got to we got to dump it and luckily
i'll pretend with this is that people
are dumping the the corporate media
nobody's really watching it anymore yeah
elijah are you telling me that we
shouldn't trust don lemon who was
vacationing in florida a couple weeks
ago after telling us that everyone there
is dying i'm shocked jake as a former
nfl player and uh an army soldier and a
young person obviously fit like can you
believe that they are trying to push
this on absolutely everybody and that
they just don't care and that when they
give you the numbers i mean the thing
that i do on every monday show after
fauci just spouts his nonsense on every
sunday show is that i talk about how on
the on the sunday shows he never gives
you numbers oh it went up 20
but that's not a number we need to know
okay well did it go from four to six
people like what are we actually talking
about here what are the ages what are
the comorbidities etc just none of it
translates anymore
i think what we're witnessing right
right now is the death in real time of
journalistic and scientific rigor and
it's important to note that because
traditionally journalism and science
have gone against the establishment
right they've always spoken truth to
power they've always been questioning
the status quo but now it's really
dangerous and totalitarian in many ways
because now mainstream corporate
journalism and mainstream quote unquote
science are now aligned with the powers
that be uh the big government the
utibrow party in washington the
mainstream press pretty much every major
major american institution all of our
colleges and universities look
everything is really aligned together in
unison and every time you see that
throughout history whether it be in the
soviet union and communist china that
has not turned out well for liberty of
free citizens and so that's that's
really the existential fight that we're
in right now i think unfortunately we
have too many politicians even in the
republican party who don't understand
the nature of that fight and that's part
of the reason why i left the military to
run for office is because that's where
the battle is that's where the fight is
and to me the stakes could not be higher
well said all right let's move on to the
to the next story which is the big one
of the week this uh jesse smallett
verdict unless you've been living under
a rock you know what happened here but
let me read a little bit from the new
york post uh jesse smallett was
convicted thursday of staging a hate
crime nearly three years after he
claimed two trump-loving bigots beat him
up tied a noose around his neck and
doused him in bleach in a misbegotten
bid to raise his public profile the
defense vehemently maintained smallett
was the victim of a real hate crime and
called the brothers sophisticated liars
and criminals who later offered to
recant their story and tell the truth in
exchange for two million dollars um
before you guys jump in there were a
whole bunch of tweets that are flying
all over the twitter sphere uh from
joe biden kamala harris so let's just
put up a couple of them i'm not going to
read all of them but joe biden kamala
harris bernie sanders aoc these are
tweets from roughly three years ago
where they all are saying this is proof
that america is racist uh homophobia and
racism have no place in our streets or
hearts um kamala harris this is a modern
attempted day lynching she still has not
deleted it aoc this attack was not
possibly homophobic it was a racist and
homophobic attack
um and you know bernie with the usual
stuff about surging hostility towards
proof uh towards minorities around the
world none of them have as far as i know
at this point deleted these tweets
obviously joe biden is not the one
handling his own phone but i'm pretty
sure the others do ah bernie doesn't
either but i'll give aoc and kamala
credit maybe they tweet for themselves
um
elijah i mean i'm sort of asking you the
same question i asked you in the
previous one but it's like the media is
not going to hold these people into
account so they can just keep lying
right they're just going to keep lying
we know they're lying they know we know
they're lying and they're going to keep
lying
yeah i'm trying not to laugh because
take this situation
and uh these are some of the loudest
voices about um
you know alleged atrocities and problems
in the world now apply
their absolute inaccuracy and their
inability to admit they were wrong to
everything else apply it to the pandemic
apply it to january 6 riot apply it to
uh you know charlottesville apply it to
anything that we never stop hearing
about today climate change right i mean
these are the people that say we're
gonna die in 12 years it's like
they're so quick to push narrative that
they don't care about the truth and then
when the truth shows their narrative was
wrong
lucky for them they're i don't even know
maybe maybe they crawled out of hell
itself i don't know where they came from
but but but these people just they're
they're intentionally aligning with the
forces that are against us the elites uh
you know the banks the media uh you know
the the
institutions of education they're all
corrupted and they're all working
together for this globalist regime that
cares nothing about about what's real or
what's uh true i mean these people
support 72 genders um they believe men
can be women i mean these are all
falsities and basic premises and i just
think that when you look at this you
this is when people need to wake up and
realize
how many more times do these people need
to be proven wrong
and fail to admit that that wrong before
you realize they might be lying about
everything else about literally
everything else i mean
brett kavanaugh as a serial rapist the
covington kids kyle rittenhouse very
fine people on both sides i mean i
covered this all this nonsense every
week i want to read a quote i want to
read a quote though from blm and jake
then i'll throw it to you because this
is pretty extraordinary this is right
before the verdict what blm said so
let's be clear we love everybody in our
community we can never believe police
especially the cpd over jesse smallette
a black man who has been courageously
present visible and vocal in the
struggle for black freedom now what's
extraordinary about that is that after
the verdict came out they have now said
the leader of black lives matter has
said that they stand by those statements
jake there's just nothing we can do to
get through to these people right
doesn't matter it's pretty it's pretty
amazing they uh they changed themselves
to the sinking ship you know as it was
going down you know into the atlantic um
which is kind of hilarious but you know
we can't really expect accountability
from these people because i think it's
important for everyone to understand
these are not journalists who are making
good faith honest mistakes okay this is
all intentional they are pushing a
narrative they're trying to move the
needle further and further left they're
working hand in hand with radical left
politicians there's been all kinds of
reporting on how some of these late
night talk show hosts talk with democrat
politicians that that's that's all on
purpose and so i think what's important
going forward is we have to find a way
you know through our political uh
leadership and culture to you know put
some more skin in the game for these
journalists who are totally out of
control not to go too deep down the
rabbit hole but i think it's important
for everyone to note that there was a
real turning point in our media's
history in this country in the mid 60s
with a supreme court decision called new
york times v sullivan which raised the
standard so astronomically high for
corporate media to be held liable for
libel and defamation and because if you
look through history politicians i mean
winston churchill sued like 30 different
publications over his long political
career for uh libel and defamation it
was kind of a tit for tat it happened
here in america too and it kept the
journalist relatively in check because
they knew they could be held liable for
civil damages if they got too out of
control with that new york times v
sullivan case that standard got way too
high for uh for actual malice for
defamation and libel and so no one has
any skin in the game they're unable to
be held to account and so they print and
say whatever they want on tv with no
accountability with no consequences and
when there's no consequences this is
never going to change so in congress you
know we can
encourage the supreme court to overturn
that decision there's kind of a legal
movement through conservative legal
circles to get that decision overturned
but also in congress we can send real
leaders to washington who can get that
decision overturned via legislation
that's a it's a hallmark priority for me
yeah you know i get it the new york
times sullivan thing it's like you want
a high bar because you want to defend
free speech and yet maybe it's gone so
crazy that now they feel they can do
anything for example the president of
the united states uh calling kyle
rittenhouse a white supremacist kyle by
the way was on uh with elijah a couple
days ago so if you guys haven't seen
that check it out matt i'm always
fascinated how this stuff leaks into
other countries so uh you're in the uk
obviously
but these things don't stay within our
borders in america what do you think the
the take is in the uk right now or
what's your take yeah no i mean we're
watching that case with a lot of
interest and actually it reminds me of a
story we tell in our book um
the the chinese state media started
quoting a swiss
molecular biologist a virologist
at great length again and again and
again and he was very very critical of
america
very critical of anybody who thought
that this virus started from a
laboratory and he's all over chinese
state media
and
then the swiss embassy in beijing said
hang on this guy wilson edwards a
virologist in switzerland we've checked
he doesn't exist right and he only
appeared on facebook a couple of months
ago um can you please explain chinese
government did you make him up
well he disappeared from facebook very
soon afterwards he's never been heard
off since he was clearly a fake fake
account um you know but that's a
government doing this kind of thing and
uh i'm sorry but you know where did he
get the idea i'm afraid there's a lot of
it around yeah and it's it's spreading
in a way that is sometimes worse than
the covid virus i would say the mind
virus around all of the misinformation
all right let's move on to the third
story so the the sort of
missing story of the week is that russia
and ukraine might go to war or something
to that effect and it's being cheered on
by an awful lot of people who make all
the wrong decisions for the last
probably three four decades here in the
united states we've got some info from
fox news uh russian president vladimir
putin has the whole world anticipating
his next move as he builds up a massive
military presence along his country's
border with ukraine with u.s officials
anticipating an imminent invasion early
next year satellite imagery obtained by
fox news on sunday highlights several
locations within western russia as well
as one location in crimea where the rush
where russian tactical battle groups
containing troops and equipment have
been deployed the plan involves
extensive movement of a hundred
battalion tactical groups with an
estimated 175 000 personnel along with
armor artillery and equipment uh jake uh
you were in the army uh well first what
do you make of uh of putin's move i
suppose but sort of secondly from an
american perspective i was watching
tucker the last couple days it's like
we're hearing a lot of people like oh
we've got to get in there and we've got
to strike russia and all this stuff and
it's like what does that have to do with
american interests with all due respect
to ukraine
yeah
for those two points first of all
i think this this russian aggression is
directly due to the weakness of joe
biden in his administration i spoke
about that during the afghanistan
debacle i think this is a direct result
of what happened in afghanistan i said
at the time it was bigger than that
withdrawal it was just the overall
incompetence uh it was clear that the
russians and the chinese were going to
test joe biden in his for in the first
year of his presidency he's being tested
he's being found wanting you know we can
revert these sanctions we can reimpose
these sanctions rather on the nordstrom
2 pipeline and introduce more economic
sanctions on russia to stop this incurs
into ukraine but i think your second
point there is even more important
because look we have to understand the
history here this is not soviet union
ussr circa 1947 okay this is not joseph
stalin who is threatening to conquer
western europe okay we can be reasonable
here um you know we can display american
strength without threatening world war
three or nuclear attacks okay you want
to be unpredictable in your tactics and
your strategy from a military
perspective but we should not be
reckless but i think that the key point
here is to
identify the weakness of president biden
and his administration this is all due
to him we saw
american strength being projected both
domestically and internationally under
president trump i know because i served
in the army as an entry officer i
deployed to iraq under president trump
we were feared we were respected and now
we are absolutely disrespected and
dishonored yeah the point on biden's
weakness and after afghanistan is a good
one because it's like putin knows he's
got a lot of leeway right now elijah are
you amazed that uh i know your answer
unfortunately that they're gonna trot
out the same people who got us into iraq
the same speechwriters the same
cast of characters who screwed
everything up with no remorse they're
gonna trot them all out again and
they're gonna say why we have to get
into some kind of war yeah i think it's
interesting here this is where the
establishment and the government the
neocons and of course the war hungary uh
democrats they're kind of the same thing
when you look at who they're getting
funded by and big tech you look where
their donors are
even some of them with the same uh you
know donors to their super pacs it's
amazing
how when we've uh inflated the economy
dave you know this we inflated the
economy our currency is down and i think
we're up for a good old war i mean
what's the cost right just uh the men
and women of our country uh young boys
young girls dying getting blown up uh
you know billions trillions possibly of
dollars of damage to the world economy
to uh property but hey you know it
serves the interest of a few people who
are powerful it doesn't do anything for
our country but you know if they want it
dave and we're only a republic right
we're only voting people in to represent
us so i mean i mean maybe one day
they'll actually actually represent us
and do something for us but i mean as
you know as a vet is on here and
realizing that these are real men this
is real women on both sides of the aisle
whether they're enemies or not we're not
we don't need another war uh you know
the pandemic's slowing down people
aren't buying the climate change bs uh
you know we're still here stuck in a
hole you know trying to get ourselves
out the supply chain and if this is
really what these global players are
trying to do god help us because this is
if biden gets us into another war
there's not there's a lot of adult words
that i won't say on a live stream that i
would like to say to these people and i
pray to god that he spares us from
another another atrocity like this
afghanistan iraq we're too much we're
finally out into an extent to them to
the severity and if this ukraine russia
thing blows over this is simply due to
incompetence if not nefarious actions
for the people that are controlling joe
biden elijah you ask too much that our
elected officials represent us i'm gonna
have to make note of it i'm gonna send a
strongly worded letter to somebody over
in dc
uh matt as the as the non-american
sitting here what what role do you think
the united states is supposed to play in
these world affairs i think often i do
think sometimes i mean i don't know
about often anymore but i think
sometimes our intentions are good and
then there's always mission creeps
sometimes the intentions are not good
sometimes you've got you know speech
writers like david frum you know telling
bush to get us into iraq so that's what
we do
what what do you think the role of the
us should be broadly
yeah well we we in europe have benefited
from american protection for 60 or 70
years and it's fantastic what's been
done to
help keep the peace particularly when
the soviet union was a threat but i
think jake's right it's not about
military now
there is a dangerous uh
world as a result of american weakness
and uh it's not just ukraine
threatened by putin but it's taiwan
threatened by
xi jinping it's what happened in hong
kong and the fact that we didn't respond
i think we have to find other ways of
responding to this and making it clear
to regimes like beijing and moscow that
their behavior is unacceptable without
going to war with them which would as
you have all said uh not be
a productive way of
reacting
i think that's the final word on this
friday show we've all agreed to not go
to war i think that's kind of
let's not go to war you know how about
that how about we defend our own borders
rather than ukraine dave how about that
i will tell you i will take that as well
uh matt elijah jake i thank you guys uh
matt and jake obviously your first time
on you're welcome back anytime elijah
you know you're welcome back anytime as
well i'm going to finish up for a few
minutes without you but thanks guys and
have a good weekend
thank you thank you
all right people uh i felt good about
that friday show not trying to make you
hysterical just trying to give you some
straight up information maybe expose
some of the nonsense some of the
hypocrites and the frauds and all of
that stuff and i think we accomplished
that uh are we making sure that matt's
book is linked down below right because
you know what happens anytime someone
puts out a roughly controversial book or
not even controversial if you put out a
book
or a video you guys all know this if you
put out anything in essence that goes
against the narrative you get hit by the
reddit trolls and everything else to
ruin your reviews and all of that stuff
so matt's book is linked uh right down
below and on that note
uh it's almost the weekend i hope you
had a good week i i feel sharp i feel
like the show was good this week i feel
like we're we're in a nice little groove
uh as i've been hinting to you guys we
got a major
announcement on monday depending on
timing it will either be announced
during our live stream
our normal show our normal live stream
at 11 am pacific on monday if not
perhaps a little bit later in the day
somewhere else not on this channel
perhaps we're working out some stuff
um
i sense some of you may know what's
going on here you know
and that being said
you want anything else about the kanye
concert i can tell the good people 90
000 people
90 90 really understand what's going on
here in los angeles 90 000 people it was
at the coliseum yeah the coliseum in los
angeles i've never been there but it's
pretty massive place
90 000 people dancing they dance people
dance to kanye you dance so they're
dancing to the kanye no masks he's
telling me which obviously is fine with
us that's just fine
um did they check they checked passports
and like all the nonsense okay whatever
um so that's happening in la while at
the same time if i would like to go to
the supermarket down the street right
now which i don't go to anymore i send
people because i can't take it anymore
if i wanted to go to the supermarket to
get some orange juice i would be have to
put on a mask and i'd most likely be
yelled at and belittled by a you know
stock boy so
anyway have a great weekend everybody
we're back on monday it's a big week
next week i promise you and i hope you
enjoy yourselves and eat good food and
drink good wine this weekend and that's
it okay see